[Música]
en Ecuador el presidente Guillermo lasso
asistió a la asamblea para defenderse en
medio del juicio político que adelante
al legislativo por presunto peculado el
mandatario aseguró que su inocencia es
total evidente e incuestionable
se le acaban las opciones al peronismo
en Argentina con miras a las próximas
elecciones presidenciales Cristina
Fernández ratificó que no será candidata
a la presidencia en un comunicado
crítico las decisiones judiciales en
contra de figuras del oficialismo a las
que calificó el juego perverso
y siguen los esfuerzos en Washington
para alcanzar un acuerdo que evite que
el país caiga en pago el presidente
biden se dijo optimista tras un
encuentro con el presidente de la cámara
de representantes Kevin mccarthy quien
dijo que las posturas siguen alejadas y
que hay mucho trabajo por delante
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
France 24 dedicado a las principales
noticias del continente americano Mi
nombre es Rodrigo sedano y es un placer
estar con ustedes abrimos este
Informativo en Ecuador allí la asamblea
del país inició Este martes una
audiencia de juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso en su
comparecencia ante el legislativo el
mandatario volvió a defender su
inocencia y señaló que el proceso en su
contra no tiene sustento el jefe de
estado podría ser destituido si 92
asambleístas así lo deciden lasso
también podría disolver el congreso yo
es Muñoz tiene los detalles
comenzó el juicio político el presidente
de Guillermo lasso se defendió ante la
asamblea nacional
han creado una situación
ficticia que no Resuelve los problemas
del pueblo ni de nadie
tras el discurso del presidente de los
137 asambleístas participarán en el
debate por un tiempo de diez minutos una
vez finalizados los discursos hay cinco
días para convocar de nuevo a la
asamblea para la votación hay distintas
posibilidades si se consiguen menos de
92 votos para destituir a lasso este
continuará en el poder de lograrlos el
vicepresidente Alfredo borrero pasaría a
ser presidente hasta el final del
mandato en 2025 otra posibilidad Es que
la corte constitucional invalide el
proceso por irregularidades Al iniciar
el juicio político algo que ha pedido
Guillermo lasso la última opción es que
el presidente invoque la muerte Cruzada
esto significaría la disolución del
Congreso y un gobierno de seis meses vía
decreto antes de que haya elecciones
esto podrían callar el proceso
nuevamente ya que la oposición podría
considerar que este mecanismo no se
puede activar en pleno juicio político
al presidente le acusan de peculado
También conocido como malversación por
un contrato del que le acu que tenía
conocimiento de las condiciones
perjudiciales para el estado y contra el
que no habría actuado lasso dice que
este contrato viene de la administración
de Lenin Moreno y que se limitaron a
obedecer las recomendaciones de la
contraloría
en Argentina el peronismo se reunió Este
martes en un consejo que sirvió para
definir su estrategia electoral de Cara
a las elecciones presidenciales de
octubre esto mientras la expresidenta
Cristina Fernández reiteró una vez más
que no se presentará como candidata
nuestro corresponsal en Buenos Aires
natalio que hoy nos amplia
Este martes tuvo lugar un congreso del
partido justicialista del peronismo
argentino en el que se escuchó el
cántico de Cristina presidenta Cristina
presidenta uno que se viene repitiendo
insistentemente en los últimos meses por
parte especialmente de la militancia más
afín a la vicepresidenta Argentina
cuando terminó ese encuentro Cristina
Fernández de kirchner emitió o dio a
conocer Una carta en sus redes sociales
y en su sitio web en la que repitió algo
que si no cuento mal ya había dicho en
tres ocasiones que es que no tiene
intenciones de presentarse como
candidata en este 2023 lo que sí puede
estar sucediendo es que esté tal vez
preparando el terreno para dar a conocer
una fórmula presidencial del frente de
todos de la coalición peronista que
actualmente está en el gobierno en
Argentina de ser así seguramente hay
algo que reconocen propios y ajenos que
es que si ella a esa fórmula esa fórmula
será la que finalmente compita por el
frente de todos y dirimiría las internas
del oficialismo de ese modo todavía sin
embargo toca seguir esperando no está
claro si hará eso o si habrá otra forma
en que se decidan los candidatos del
oficialismo para las elecciones
presidenciales de este año mientras que
en Estados Unidos continúa el debate
sobre la píldora abortiva mi fe pristona
y justamente se espera que este
miércoles tres jueces decidan si seguirá
siendo de libre acceso en el país en
Argentina se amplió su uso Andrés
triviño no se emplea
mientras Estados Unidos se debate entre
posibles restricciones al uso de la
píldora abortiva Argentina amplía su uso
luego de que la administración Nacional
de medicamentos alimentos y tecnología
médica aprobara el libre acceso de la
mifepristona el pasado marzo he visto
morir muchas chicas jóvenes que llegaban
con abortos sépticos y con
insuficiencias renales agudas que eran
imposibles de rescatar con shock
multisistémico y realmente cuando uno
tiene esa experiencia de vida
definitivamente quedas marcada y vas a
la búsqueda de esa solución Argentina
fue el más reciente país en dar luz
verde a la mifepristona reflejando una
expansión de los derechos reproductivos
junto con países como Colombia Bolivia
México y chile donde el medicamento ya
Es legal mientras que en otros como Perú
Brasil y El Salvador sigue prohibido o
su acceso es muy restringido la
mifepristona se combina con misoprostol
logrando un 96% de efectividad y es
utilizado en más de la mitad de todos
los abortos en Estados Unidos
le está indicando misoprostol solo uno
le tiene que decir a la mujer que la
tasa de falla es del 15%. mientras que
ahora con la mifepristona uno le tiene
que decir solamente la tasa de falla es
de un 3% en Estados Unidos el
medicamento fue aprobado por la
administración de drogas y alimentos fda
en el año 2000 pero recientemente grupos
antiaborto buscan prohibir el
medicamento argumentando que la agencia
gubernamental se equivocó e ignoró
supuestos riesgos para la salud
también en Estados Unidos finalizó la
segunda reunión entre el presidente Joe
biden y los líderes del Congreso sobre
la ampliación del techo de la deuda
biden se dijo optimista tras el
encuentro sin embargo el presidente de
la cámara baja el republicano Kevin
mccarthy resaltó que esta reunión fue
más productiva Pero eso no quiere decir
que se vaya a llegar a un acuerdo
temprano
creo que preparamos el escenario para
llevar a cabo más conversaciones sabes
Sólo quedan 15 días Tenemos que
encontrar una forma de curvar nuestros
gastos aumentar nuestro límite de deuda
y también hacer crecer nuestra economía
y el presidente accedió a Designar a un
par de personas de su administración
para que se sentaran y negociaran
directamente con mi equipo así que me
pareció productivo personalmente pero
tenemos mucho trabajo por hacer en poco
tiempo
en Washington también el director de
Open ahí la empresa de Inteligencia
artificial que lanzó chadty testificó
ante el congreso allí propuso la
creación de una agencia estadounidense o
mundial que concediera licencias a los
sistemas de Inteligencia artificial más
potentes el laurel con los detalles
la Inteligencia artificial tiene el
potencial de mejorar casi todos los
aspectos de nuestras vidas pero también
crea graves riesgos
Esas son las palabras de samantman el
jefe de la empresa o hay que está detrás
de la aplicación
frente a una comisión del senado
estadounidense urgió por regulaciones y
pidió la cooperación de los estados a
nivel mundial para mitigar los impactos
de esta nueva tecnología herramientas
con mucha gpt han generado temores sobre
la capacidad de la Inteligencia
artificial de violar los derechos de
autor destruir puestos de trabajo o
crear noticias falsas un escenario
preocupante de Cara a las próximas
elecciones en Estados Unidos
es una de las áreas que más me preocupan
la capacidad más general de estos
modelos para manipular persuadir
proporcionar una especie de
desinformación interactiva uno a uno
por eso un grupo de expertos pide que
hay otras empresas pausen su desarrollo
de modelos más potentes durante seis
meses y así dar a la sociedad más tiempo
para considerar los riesgos también
necesitamos científicos independientes
no solo para que los científicos
tengamos voz sino para que podamos
participar directamente en el
tratamiento de los problemas y la
evaluación de las soluciones y no solo
después de que se lancen productos sino
antes Por el momento no hay indicios
inmediatos de que el congreso
estadounidense vaya a elaborar nuevas
normas sobre la Inteligencia artificial
como están haciendo los legisladores en
Europa
cerramos en Perú el país ha recuperado
36 piezas culturales que estaban en
Estados Unidos según informó el
Ministerio de relaciones exteriores
peruano se trata de 28 textiles antiguos
tres pinturas virreinales una cabeza de
momia un fardo funerario de nazca y
cabeza reducidas de árboles suar según
el gobierno cerca de 2.000 piezas se han
recuperado los últimos cuatro años
con estas imágenes Nos despedimos ya
conectados a France 24
[Música]